all right favorite food favorite food  Italian favorite season of the year uh  winner favorite sneaker mine which one  of yours  favorite album favorite album of all  time oh my goodness wow I only got one  album that's almost impossible okay give  me like top careers uh okay it was  written by Nas The Black Album by Jay-Z  and I don't know I don't know that's  hard favorite movie uh The Godfather  wanting to favorite tattoo that you have  anyone that got my kids on it so I got  my kids all over me the names and faces  so anyone with the kids favorite player  growing up Kendrick favorite opposing  City to play in well a favorite NBA  memory getting drafted